Where do I even begin?
Well, let’s start with small steps.
Is there anything we can help you with tonight
before you get some sleep?
I don’t even know where my parents
and I are going to sleep tonight...
Well, I heard they’re converting a local school
into temporary accommodation,
shall we go over and get a room for you and your parents?
Ah, I didn’t know they were doing that.
Sure, that sounds like a good first step.
Raul! Good morning, how are you?
Carlos, welcome to my home, or what’s left of it...
My leg has almost healed
and your colleagues have been helping
me to clear up the debris.
It’s almost ready for us to build a new ranch.
Wow, that’s great!
Did you know the mayor is arriving tomorrow?
Apparently, she will unveil more relief packages.
Oh, really?
Great, I wonder if it will help
to rebuild my ranch any quicker.
If you come to the announcement,
I can also introduce you to some of the volunteers
that just finished building a new church.
Maybe they can help with your ranch too?
Then, we can get a cup of that famous coffee
you’ve been telling me about!
You’re on!
But first, how about you put these
gloves on and help me clear this area?
Yes boss!